whenever we've talked about cases of
discrimination by businesses oftentimes
the case of the gay wedding cake and I
think Colorado comes up you often see
sexual orientation by the way what's a
gay wedding I just saw a stupid way too
it's it's it exposes the absurdity of
the case by calling it that you often
hear sexual orientation compared to
political orientation right people will
say to me when I say I don't believe you
are allowed to refuse service to a
customer on the basis of their being gay
if sexual orientation is a protected
class I'll get emails saying David if
you can't refuse service to someone for
being gay then you can't refuse service
to someone for being a Republican and of
course I've always held that there's
this thing called the law because I'm a
law and order progressive this thing
called the law in most states actually
does allow for refusing to serve someone
on the basis of their politics because
political orientation and affiliation
are not protected classes depending on
what state you're in like in Washington
DC interestingly political affiliation
is a protected class Washington DC is
also not a state so in most states
sexual orientation may be a protected
class race religion and nationality are
basically always protected classes you
can't refuse service to someone because
they're black or Christian or Italian
but not listed there for the most part
our political allegiances there's
nothing in the law that says a business
can't say we don't serve Republicans or
we don't serve Democrats or we don't
serve Green Party voters as long as
they're not also discriminating along
the basis of a protected class we've got
a court decision from a Manhattan judge
this week who says that a bar that threw
out a trump supporter a 31 year old
named Greg Pia tick or pie addict who
was bounced from a bar last year for
wearing a make America great again hat
he sued and ultimately the judge said
not a protected class political beliefs
are simply not protected and Greg
through his lawyer in the lawsuit made
the argument that being thrown out for
wearing the Hat offended his sense of
being American and they actually tried
to argue
they didn't say that his support of
Trump was a religious belief but they
said that it was part of his
spirituality which is kind of a cop-out
it's a way of trying to say it's a
religious belief in any case the judge
didn't fall for it the drug judge said
supporting Trump is not a religious
belief and came back and said there's no
reason whatsoever for this lawsuit to go
forward and it's the obviously correct
decision
yeah and interestingly enough it's
usually the right-wingers who are
against protected statuses sure and also
against the safe spaces as we call them
yeah so this is a little bit backwards
here it seems when it's not good for
them all of a sudden the perspective is
totally different and I do want to say
that there is a little bit of a gray
area here which is that even though
political beliefs are not a religion
it's true that for a lot of Trumpets
their unconditional and dogmatic support
for Trump is actually not that different
than dogmatic religious beliefs legally
in the eyes of the law that still
doesn't make this a protected
perspective when it comes to business
service to just be a supporter of Donald
Trump yeah it just doesn't feel right
though like I understand your political
beliefs in most areas not a protected
status yeah but I don't think I would
patronize a bar or restaurant that
refused Republicans or trumpets from
going into it I would you'll write to me
I have no problem with it like what
would feel do you believe that if you go
there and you you patronize the
restaurant that you're encouraging
political divisive nasai also just feels
like a little bit reminiscent of the Jim
Crow era in a way I know it's a lot more
getting race I get that but what would
they have a sign on the door that says
like no Trump supporters allowed I
couldn't get behind them you know what
they don't have to because if someone
goes in there and is a trump supporter
and they're not wearing a make America
great again hat which you could argue is
just a fashion statement but you could
all you argue is also in Manhattan's
West Village after all something
deliberately meant to get a reaction no
one knows your politics if you go into a
bar and you're not wearing something
that says I'm a Republican or whatever
and you order a drink you're not being
refused service on the basis of who you
voted for because no one knows who you
voted for what the bar basically did is
evaluate a behavioral decision which was
to wear the hat so I don't think we can
say that it's the same as a sign that
says no Republicans I know I mean
our other things though that you can
hide like your religion you can also
hide it's not a parent just from sitting
at the bar that it could be for sexual
more sexual orientation as well I just
don't feel like it feels American to me
so I would avoid a bar a restaurant that
did that personally patriotic Pat makes
a return yeah that's a character that
will everyone so now that it's a fake
character I just mean it's a part of
your persona that will sometimes rear
its head
you see uh Milan innopolis was thrown
out of a bar you mentioned that to me
yeah yeah isn't a safe enough space for
him apparently I guess the Democratic
socialists of America didn't want him
there and they jammed him out a story
for another day
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between you
wager on predictions about real world
events using futures in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube this week on futur I pose the
question will there be a congressional
hearing regarding the Trump sexual
assault allegations what do you think
click the link in the description and
place your bets and you can browse the
politics category on futur to wager on
other predictions sign up now at
futurecom and start making your
forecasts on political topics and tons
of other topics totally free available
on both Android and iOS as well as on
web browsers that is fut you you are
calm